wird ihnen präsentiert von der leyen für
alle wohl engert oder weniger lang weg
sind vom berner oberland in den
spanischen süden miriam thomas buckley
erfüllen sich den traum vom leben auf
einer pferde finca auf einer großen farm
im westen kanadas will familie ruckstuhl
endlich ihr glück finden
mit vier tigern sagt remo müller das
abenteuer erwandert zu seiner freundin
alexandra pitz nach deutschland aus sie
bauen einen tierpark
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr
der tiertransporter fährt im wald dazu
in gaza vor
hier hat remo müller elf jahre lang als
tierpfleger und koch gearbeitet heute
wanderte aus im gepäck seine vier
sibirischen tiger sie gar nicht getragen
und der notarzt und ein pharma ist jetzt
gut dass es losgeht weil man da mal über
soul sind denn nicht transportiert wird
heuer checkt ob die tiere munter und
reisefertig sind
[Musik]
die tiger sind bereit nur der
auswanderer selber hat seinen platz noch
nicht gefunden hat von seminaren er
hofft dass gott nicht besucht maria ich
jetzt nicht aber ich habe meine und elf
jahren und ich das gemerkt aberglaube
ist noch zwei drei wochen also ich habe
das habe ich relativ gut sie machte
einfach und studieren jetzt viel links
und rechts um
ich glaube dass ich im moment auf helmes
freundin alexandra teetz für den tiger
konvoi an
im anhänger trainingsutensilien für die
raubkatzen in der letzten folge von auf
und davon meldete sich remo müller in
der schweiz ab eine einfache formalität
tiger einpacken hingegen das brauchte
viel geduld
[Musik]
familie ruckstuhl verabschiedete sich
auf dem bauernhof von den eltern tochter
josefin die mit einer schweren
stoffwechselkrankheit zur welt kam hatte
ihre letzte arzt visite in der schweiz
mirian thomann und ursli verabschiedeten
sich von ihrem schäferhund lobo während
merian noch in der schweiz zurück blieb
kam es bereits in der neuen heimat in
andalusien an
[Musik]
der tiger konvoi konnte den ball
ungehindert passieren
noch sind sie gut 350 kilometer vom ziel
entfernt
keine heimat mehr und noch kein neues
team ich denn das anders denn sie mir
auch und wenn wir fragen wir mal partei
markthändler ob ist ja immer nur das
fahren das ist schnell und kontrolliert
und probiert zu schaffen und dann kommt
wieder dabei und 76 wir können nach
vorne fahren
zwei jahre lang ist remo zwischen den
deutschen bell und der schweiz gependelt
nun bleibt er für immer da sein neues
zuhause ist ein stillgelegter tierpark
im matsch
wir werden ausladen und da okay besten
schnell stoppen dann checken wir erstmal
die lage das was im moment wie man dann
einfach nur das nicht fehlerlos nummer
nicht sondern das wirkt fungiert als
erstes begrüßt in sein künftiger
schwiegervater
eigentlich bräuchte remo absolute ruhe
aber es wimmelt von schaulustigen sogar
eine deutsche fernsehstation fängt das
ereignis halo kontrolliert noch mal die
tiger stellung
wir machen ist also eher wird
abbaustätte der worden teilte um
entspannter tag gemacht und noch heute
der tina und sie war dass er hinter gott
damit die nächste wieder platzen zum
chatten
das ist dreifach gesichert alles und es
kontrolliert aber ausnahmen terminale
lead user und einfach
das läuft gut muss ich fertig alles
gerichtet wiener loch
[Musik]
in andalusien nächtigt us partie vorerst
in einem der gästezimmer der pferde
finca allein seine freundin miriam
arbeitet noch in der schweiz längst
nicht nur aus das leben auf der pfähle
finca ist voller abenteuer abwechslung
und arbeit 26 hektar groß ist das
gepachtete anwesen von den 70 pferden
besitzt uns über die hälfte
diese kennen zu lernen das ist nun seine
große aufgabe die anderen gehören seinem
geschäftspartner robert reiter robert
ist ein alter pferdeflüsterer und mit
den edlen andalusien bestens vertraut
[Applaus]
langsam muss ist das vertrauen der
pferde gewinnen der bauernbub ist zwar
mit tieren groß geworden doch erfahrung
mit feurigen rasse pferden hatte noch
keine sechs monate ist es her dass die
beiden die pferde finca los angeles
besichtigt haben
die begeisterung war groß und der
besitzer der finger war schnell bereit
den hof den beiden zu verpachten
nur eine bedingung stellte er es müsse
die zuchtpferde kaufen
ja die füchse mit besichtigung und der
schweiz - und das geht komplett die lage
center über diese drei minuten
das hatte damals keine zeit sucht
papiere und jedes einzelne pferd zu
überprüfen
mit hilfe eines ferien gastes check der
nun ob die implantierten chips mit der
zucht liste übereinstimmen 75 83 95 100
75 83 95
sein damaliges bauchgefühl bestätigt
sich alles hat seine richtigkeit
geschäftspartner robert halter hatte
jahrelang einen kleinen reithof geführt
auf jedem hof lernten sich die beiden
kennen
sie freundeten sich an und beschlossen
gemeinsam einen reitbetrieb zu
übernehmen
mit der fähre finca los angeles ist
dieser traum in erfüllung gegangen
noch ist die reitschule das wichtigste
standbein des betriebes um aber rentabel
zu sein müssen sie pferde verkaufen
ein profil trainiert die zuchttiere
täglich
sparen ist hof werke sind das ist der
markt entspricht absoluten boden aus
wirtschaftlichen und news im beruf das
ist einfach dreist und bietet zusätzlich
noch dazu dass sie dazu und plötzlich
hat man runterfällt
und das geht nicht also mit mühseligen
wir am markt
probiere zur offene schweiz deutschland
frankreich aber da muss natürlich erst
mal ganz export kanal muss man sich
erarbeiten und eine strategie
zurechtlegen
[Musik]
eine umarmung zur landung kessel holt
familie ruckstuhl am flughafen calgary
ab für die farm besitzerin hatten
alexandra und markus bereits bei ihrer
ersten auswanderung gearbeitet mit
ruckstuhl sun gekommen ist familienhund
chips sie und ihr ganzes hab und gut
gerade mal 13 gepäckstücke sind es
sie fahren zurück an den ort den sie vor
knapp eineinhalb jahren verlassen hatten
weil töchterchen josephine schwer krank
war
wirklich bewundernswert dass ihr den weg
noch mal auf euch genommen habe ja ich
weiß nicht ob wir mutig oder einfach nur
dumm sind wahrscheinlich beides
ich fühlte mich einfach nicht wohl in
der schweiz die schweiz ist ja so klein
selbst wenn du auf dem land bist bist du
nicht wirklich auf dem land unberührtes
land gibt es ja dort kaum familie
ruckstuhl zieht erneut in das häuschen
ein dass sie damals bewohnt hatte
[Musik]
umgerechnet 370 franken im monat
bezahlen sie für die 90 quadratmeter
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr hoffentlich erholen
auch vater markus ist zufrieden
zufrieden weil er hier in kanada den
kindern das bieten kann was er sich in
der schweiz kaum hätte leisten können
bis 15
das einzige
[Musik]
auch remo ist mit wenig gepäck
ausgewandert doch sein gepäck ist schwer
die kiste mit der 160 kilo schweren
tigerin rani der das erste an der
öffnung zur tiger strahlung angebracht
mit spannrahmen musik ist eher
festgezurrt werden
die tigerin könnte sonst die box einfach
weg schleudern
[Musik]
was ich letztlich doch mal hab ich gar
nicht ich glaub du dich mach doch wieder
zu
du bist mir herum
jetzt kommt die partie nur an die reihe
für das 250 kilo schwere männchen
braucht es sogar einen traktor remo ist
erleichtert dass weibchen rani sicher im
käfig ist frau nicht fragt also es ist
jetzt hinter der sich die let's talk
schiene robusteres logisch und alles und
vor dem
sehr gut seine menschen seine schon auf
wenn er nachher dass das siegen ist will
findet sie super leistung dass er helfen
teilt das doch das männchen timo lässt
sich zeit
am besten sachsen waren einfach im
moment also ich glaube das ist das
allerbeste list aus und dann warten
einen kleinen moment um wirklich ruhe zu
haben schickt remo die helfer weg und
bleibt allein bei thema
[Musik]
übrigens für alles gut weil ich jetzt
mehr so hässlich und ordinär kraft zu
gerne habe ich immer weniger
kontrollieren
der britisch oder nicht wieder fit dass
er ihn als das erste übernachtet
[Musik]
einzig freundin alexandra teetz hat mit
ihm aus remo ist bis jetzt die ruhe weg
aber er hat generell sehr viel geduld
aber das braucht man glaube ich auch als
trainer gearbeitet dass man dann die
geduld aufbringen kann
[Musik]
in einem kleinen häuschen mitten in der
natur hat eine glückliche familie die
erste nacht verbracht ganz wohl fühlt
sie hatten dieses kleine paradies
verlassen als sie erfuhren dass ihre
tochter an einer lebensbedrohlichen
stoffwechselkrankheit leidet zur
behandlung der kleinen kehrte die
familie in die schweiz zurück diese
behandlung eine
stammzellentransplantation verlief
erfolgreich und auch in kanada wird
tochter josephine weiter gut betreut
werden
[Musik]
josef ins krankheit hat das leben der
eltern für immer verändert es gibt ein
leben vor und nach der diagnose
[Musik]
ja du jetzt geht's los los also die
sachen des vormieters weg räumen
dabei stoßen sie auf altbekanntes der
100 jahre im keller wussten sie auch
dinge die sie bei ihrer überstürzten
abreise zurücklassen mussten ran de toni
er bedeutet toaster aber den denn allzu
starke worte nicht kommentiert
das ist super ich auf der liste stand
aber moment geholt
diese lampe ruiniert
[Musik]
es heißt das glück auf erden liege auf
dem rücken der pferde
allein es fehlt noch etwas
es ist traumhaft
im berner oberland hat freundin miriam
tormann keine zeit für lange
telefongespräche
sie waren dann aus dann alles gute mein
freund und ich lassen uns in andalusien
nieder
zusammen mit 79 kehrten in der politik
herrscht hochbetrieb
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nur noch wenige tage dann läuft miriam
thomas arbeitsvertrag aus und auch sie
kann endlich nach spanien auswandern und
mit conferences sind
[Musik]
im tier erlebnispark im bett sind einzig
und allein die hunde schon munter mitten
im park wohnen alexandra und remo
endlich zusammen
erst nach mitternacht sprang der letzte
tiger in seine neue stellung und die
beiden konnten schlafengehen aber froh
dass alle dinge ring das alles nicht
remo und seine tierpflege kollegin aus
der schweiz sind die einzigen die in
diesen ersten tagen zu den tigern hinein
dürfen
wir müssen glaube mir heute morgen wenn
remo pustet dann wissen die tiger dass
alles in ordnung ist
mutter liest ja langsam wieder alles gut
hätte ich nur sehr misstrauisch aber mit
aufgeregt oder so remo kennt seine
katzen
sie brauchen viel zeit und ruhe um sich
an die neue umgebung zu gewöhnen
[Musik]
kimi
schon früh am morgen noch bevor sich die
südspanische hitze über die reit finger
legt wollen us und sein geschäftspartner
robert klare verhältnisse schaffen
er beschrieb betrieb zu beschäftigen
der zucht- und denen ein ich bin für
stunden sagen wie es kommt ihr ich tue
das graben - diskutieren werden wird in
den entscheid ross und was im
ritterlichen bericht entscheiden wofür
und umzu bereich der shadow und munter
musiker schon sagen schon zweimal schlug
fertig aber wir schreiben nicht
diskussion lernen und sich mit ihr über
das vertrauen das mir nicht ganz so gar
kein motiv lag sie im kamin nach langen
monaten gönnt sich urs einen ritt auf
seinem lieblingspferd lanzelot der
hengst war das allererste pferd das er
gekauft hat und es ist das einzige das
ihm eigentlich bereits vertrauen sollte
martin karlhofer beschluss fällt mit
einer noch sei dies passiert durch
[Applaus]
lufthansa bot
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer sich natürlich adrenalin pur will
wenn man auf ihn setzt dass manager
bierbaum
[Musik]
in kanada richtet sich die familie
ruckstuhl erneut ein dass ich nicht bei
ihnen erst so oft das andere tun rosa
ist ein altes haus und neuem platz zu
machen
[Applaus]
als erstes haben alexandra und markus
ein kleines sofa gekauft
[Musik]
keine zeit für eine pause und auch wenn
ihr neues zuhause nur gemietet ist
[Musik]
ihren garten dürfen sie um flügen wie
sie wollen und anbauen was sie wollen
im großen stil eigenes gemüse
anzupflanzen
das war mit ein grund warum die familie
ausgewandert ist
[Applaus]
der major lägen derzeit immer schnell
das sehr gerne herzschlag einzuholen
mit kuhdung frisch von den rindern vor
der haustür bereitet markus das erste
gemüsebeet vor und die kleine josephine
lernt dabei so wie alle kinder lernen
sie amtieren vater nach so alexandra
pflanzt gemüsezwiebeln dass sie ihre
arbeit ungestört nachgehen kann das war
nicht immer so gerne nach dem nachtisch
ende gegangen
das hätte sowieso unterstützt
bin ich aus der sehr sehr dankbar
[Musik]
nur noch leere kisten erinnern im
deutschen bell an die große tiger zu
klettern
der tierpark stammt aus den 70er jahren
als in alexandra und remo vor zwei
jahren kauften begannen sie ihn
umzubauen
alle tiere sollen ein neues gehege
bekommen ein ehrgeiziges vorhaben nur
wenige wochen vor der eröffnung liegt
nämlich noch vieles im matsch
die hunde halle ist bereits in betrieb
sie ist alexandras domäne
hier trainiert sie ihre haus 100
[Musik]
es wurden auch ein hund der die beiden
vor vier jahren zusammen gebracht hat
[Musik]
bleibt bleibt bleibt linke auch kleine
hunde müssen sitzen bleibt ja wir haben
uns ja dadurch kennen das remo sich ein
border collie holen wollte und er hat
eine trainerin gesucht die ihm dann
hilft beim und dann quasi kontaktiert ob
ich schauen kann wo man ein border
collie hektisch der zu ihm passen können
die informationen geben kann
ja das war natürlich dann im am anfang
der mittelpunkt unserer hunde im
training daraus ist das ganze dann
empfangen die border collie dame kehrer
die alexandra remo schließlich empfohlen
hatte
noch langsam aber gut hast du auch gibt
ja mit dem genau dasselbe gemacht dem
ernst ja sie kann es manchmal schon an
den bußgang gekauft damit winkel felder
karten irgendwo von einer vision
marktstr endet weil die 600 hatten wir
auch schon in der schweiz waren ja
eigentlich gar keines gefunden oder zu
mir oder kaufe mit 456 haben und dann
haben wir ja irgendwie und frauen sich
unmöglich dass mir irgendwo zweimal
auftreten will eben am schafberg gb und
die augen woche nach möglichkeit zu mir
dass ich auch nur noch spaß
das ist genau das was man ein melder sei
man sich mit russland geld das ich cool
bleiben
[Musik]
im kanadischen städtchen nennen ist
markus ruckstuhl auf einkaufstour dem
cowboy aus der ostschweiz fehlt die
richtige arbeitskleidung das cowboy
country macht männer erst zur richtigen
cowboys zumindest äußerlich fast magisch
zieht es markus zu den cowboystiefeln
stiefel sind seine kleine leidenschaft
[Musik]
zu schaffen an die die romandie im
keller gefunden
aber es gibt eine schöne sache und
wirklich schöne gut ist sehr gut vor
allem schönheit ist mir nicht so wichtig
an funktionalität die verlockung ist da
doch der genügsame schweizer probiert
nur das was er wirklich braucht
[Musik]
selbst ein richtiger cowboy hut kann
markus nicht zum kauf verführen
als willkommensgeschenk leistet sich der
swisscoy eine neue baseball-kappe
[Musik]
nach einer woche in andalusien zieht usd
auf der stuten beide ein erstes fazit
[Musik]
wenn man mit so wunderschöne tiere mit
überalterung möchte erst einmal schaffen
also das sich von minus der lagequalität
das ist definitiv das perfekt dass alles
absolut perfekt der staat hat miriam
einen hektischen tag hinter sich
so viel selbstvertrauen und zuversicht
wie ios hat miriam nicht immer wenn sie
allein ist beschleichen sie manchmal
ängste sie die leidenschaftliche köchin
wird in spanien mitverantwortlich für
die große finca küche sein weil das
sorgerecht auswandern heißt neues
terrain zu betreten
oft auch sich selber völlig neu zu
erfinden
die chance beraubt wie das zürcher
seebecken die ausnahme das ist im moment
die größte chance dieses jahr trotz
manchmal mulmigem gefühl
miriam will die chance packen in der
nächsten folge von offen davon steht der
schweizer cowboy vor seiner ersten
großen aufgabe
magazin
tochter josefin hat ihre erste
untersuchung im spital in bell hat remo
geburtstag alexandra überraschten mit
einem geschenk was ist es seine tiger
betreten zum ersten mal die arena auch
mirian ist in spanien angekommen
es bahnt sich ein erster konflikt an und
miriam bereitet stimmt der yuna für den
verkauf vor
[Musik]
große stücke mit
auf und davos präsentiert wurde der
leyen will olivo längert oder weniger
lang weg sind